all right carissa
hi hi chris where are you from
originally i am from rialto
the inland empire
and tell me about your your family
um
so i grew up with both of my parents
i really came from like a loving home
i i didn't really have a really like
traumatic childhood
like most girls you know
um
both my parents
siblings as well
um i feel like the only traumatic thing
that ever happened to me while
well one of the things that happened to
me while i was a child was basically um
i was six years old
and then
i
was diagnosed with diabetes
type one so juvenile type diabetic
whatever
that happened at six
how has that affected your life now
um
i'm not really on top of my medication
like that so
if you're not on top of your medication
you have to go to the hospital a lot and
then you just miss out on like a lot of
money being in the hospital because i'll
be in the icu for like three days four
days because i'm sick
but um it's gonna be tough with the
lifestyle you're leading yeah
it doesn't correlate together you don't
go together no
at all how would you describe your
childhood in general sounds pretty good
right um
it was okay
we grew up well i grew up really humbled
my parents did the best that they could
i've always had clothes on my back and a
roof over my head
food in my stomach
maybe i didn't get what i wanted all the
time
but um
they did good
you're very exotic looking where are
your parents from
so my mom is from nicaragua
um and my dad is from panama
so your
part
so okay so mom nicaraguan dad
pandymanian my nana is from jamaica
so i'm basically hispanic and black
there you go
how far did you go to school
i graduated high school yeah
so what led you
to the streets doing this kind of work
it always starts with that one guy
it always starts with that one guy did
he start out as a boyfriend
um
kind of he was interested in me
and i guess his friend was the one that
told him hey like you should like
pimp on her
whatever
oh yeah bro okay
so i i guess i was the one or whatever
how do you make that jump from
being a teen you were a teenager yeah i
was at 17. 17. how did you how do you
make the transition from
a 17 year old girl who probably has
you know
would like to have a boyfriend
to
getting into a situation where you're
turning dates
and bringing him the money i assume you
know what i was never really good with
guys
like i i've i've always had
bad luck with men and relationships and
stuff
um
so just
i feel like having
somebody
who
i guess truly cares about you and about
your safety and
you know like
cares about you and stuff but you're
paying them i guess whatever it just it
felt good at the moment
how long did that last
[Music]
um
honestly i didn't like a couple months
not long
yeah a couple months or whatever and
then i left
and then
i went into college
for about
a year
and
it was
it was getting too much for when i
didn't have no like fafsa no
scholarships or not nothing like that
so i was the one like paying out of
pocket for everything
so it just
it was just a
lot you're 23 now mm-hmm you have do you
have a pimp now yeah you do
it's a better situation than this
way better
he actually cares so so there are some
relationships with pimps yeah of course
that are that are beneficial
yeah i mean i don't know much about
other people's you know folks and pimps
or whatever whatever
but um my relationship with my folks
like it's it's really amazing
i i love it
you still give him the money but he
what does he do in return
um it's okay so for one
my folks he
knows how to save
as a female
especially me because i like to you know
buy everything and anything
but um he knows how to save he knows how
to invest in the proper
things
um
when
i've been with him i've never had
certain things
so
an apartment
a car
i've
no like he
he really helped me a lot so you you now
have an apartment in a car you do
i think what a lot of
people don't understand about girls that
do this kind of work is
i would guess close to 90 95 of the
girls are terrible with handling money
and that that's where
a good pimp can come in and
manage your money yeah and i feel like a
lot of people
a lot of squares or a lot of like normal
normies you know
they don't understand like damn like why
would you sell your body and give it to
a whole other guy you know
but
first of all like that's just how the
game goes i feel like
you you you can't disrespect the game
i personally wouldn't
okay so i've been on both sides of the
fence so i've been a square going to
college 5-5 going to college i've been a
renegade
and then i've had folks
so the reason
why i'm
with my folks right now
for one safety by all means if i need
him if i really really need him i can
call him and he'll be there like that
but college wasn't safe
college was safe i guess but it's just
like
i just couldn't do it it's the
another part of the puzzle here
that mystifies people that don't
understand is
long-term gratification is a foreign
language to you guys
you guys don't understand that like
college is about long-term gratification
you you put in the four years and then
you might get a better job at the end of
it and you know what's crazy my
sister she's
the first graduate of like a college and
stuff so like
yeah yeah so she she did it
she did it but
most most of the girls that are doing
this kind of work are like i just need
that money for tonight
i'm gonna spend every time of it and
then tomorrow i'll do it again it's all
about short-term gratification and
sometimes you don't even get anything
one night you can make a hundred dollars
not me but
yeah
but um there's days where you don't make
anything
like and there's days where you make
times more than what you thought you
were going to make
what what's your ideal kind of
customer
customer
clientele trick client trick whatever is
it so many terms
um
hispanic men a lot of hispanic men
a lot of hispanic men
um
some whites
it depends if they're not like the
police
some whites um
black men
um you have to be like
really older like you're about a croak
old
for me today shooting your black because
otherwise they're what hustlers
they're either trying to rob you rape
you or pimp you out
yeah i've got
i was just being thirsty
and
the night was being slow and stuff and i
had dated um
you know blacks that ended up
either
robbing me
raping me i've had um one that kidnapped
me before
but yeah yeah all the girls have those
stories
it's sad but your current folks are
african-american
they're current
my folks yeah yeah he's african-american
and is it a romantic relationship for
you as well no he's not my boyfriend
he's not and there are other girls in
his camp yeah i have a wifey yeah she's
great too
it's not
nothing like no like boyfriend
girlfriend it's not like a jealousy type
of
situation it's just
we're all here trying to just get out
the game
trying to be better than we are
today and yesterday
so
do you recall your very first time doing
this
um
it was this
um i think it was like why or
something i don't i don't know he was
like why it was an alcohol
because at that moment i don't i wasn't
sure why but the person that i was
paying at that time
he never wanted to get rooms
i don't know i'm like okay whatever it
was alcohol up in hollywood
i come
um
go to i i think it was like
a whole a hotel or something like that i
felt honest i forgot but i go
and
i had came inside
and at first like like i was scared
because it was like my first time
it was this older like white guy i'm
like ill like i don't want to do this
this is so disgusting
um but he had ended up
giving me i think it was like 350
for like 10 minutes so then i was just
like i'm on top of the world oh my god
it wasn't so bad
no it wasn't that bad
it wasn't like
it was weird you know because it was
like my first time but then i'm like
damn like if i could make 350 in 10
minutes
i could for sure do this
is it just a matter of getting over the
no pun intended hump of of having sex
with strangers getting that
hurdle out the way yeah yeah yeah
because you're you're having sex with
people that are not age-appropriate i
assume yeah probably have bad hygiene
yeah no one thing about me um
i won't date you
if you stink
i will not date you if you smell i don't
smell so why do you smell and i've been
outside
oh i just came from work well baby you
need to go take a shower or something
because i'm not gonna date you
but if you come into my room and you
smell for one i'm gonna still
keep my money
you can you know go take a shower and
stuff
and then that's just how it is
it's got to be a hard life
sometimes it is
sometimes because you're not attracted
to these guys right yeah
if you're attracted to a trick you are
green
you are a you're you're super green or
you're a crystal man
something
are drugs a part of your life no i don't
even smoke weed you don't even smoke
food no i don't smoke weed
um i drink alcohol but not while i'm
working i like no i can't i can't do
that yeah
super sober
good for you
you ever get arrested or hassled by the
cops yeah
got arrested oh sorry i got arrested um
[Music]
a couple times
the cops generally leave you guys alone
though
mostly like you outnumber them
mostly i know vice
like they know me they they know my face
they'll be like oh miss
last name
and i'm like
yeah that's me
goom
i'm like you know i'm not
[Music]
how is this doing this work affect you
emotionally
um
you get numb to it
yeah you get
numb to it you get used to it
there there's times where um
i'm just sad
i'm just super super sad and it's
only because like it's not going as fast
as i'd like it to
you want to make quick money yeah
there's there's times where you'll stand
outside for hours
and not make nothing if you could do
four dates an hour you'd be happy
something like
at like
just fast dates fast dates are like the
best when those are like your like your
fast days you think okay like it's gonna
be like this every single day no it's
not and it's crazy because there's so
many people like oh you're so pretty
like you must catch so many dates and
this and that and that no
there's days where like
ah just it's just it's so irritating and
i just want to like just be in my bed
and go
sometimes
when i'm driving down on fig i'll see
some of the most beautiful females that
ever walk the planet there's a lot of
girls
super super attractive women who are
standing out there and i'm like so i'll
drive around the block come back later
and she's still there
yeah and then she's still there an hour
i can't figure it out because there's
certainly enough guys cruising up and
down the street yeah
it's crazy i i don't
people don't understand that um
just because you're pretty
it doesn't mean anything
literally does not mean anything a lot
of tricks out of john's
they're attracted to
body type
you know so you could have a pretty face
with no body for one
and
most john's most tricks like they're not
gonna date you
because pretty faces don't mean nothing
yeah there's all shapes and sizes out
there shape slices and your mouthpiece
too for sure
did you have dreams of doing something
else with your life other than this yeah
um i want to go back to school
i really want to go back to school yeah
well you're young enough to do that i
know
and so you have an apartment
you have a car you have a pretty good
setup yep i do
would you describe yourself as happy
um
i feel like that's probably not the word
i mean am i a happy person yeah do you
seem to be yeah yeah yeah i am happy but
you realize that there's a better life
out there for you
not a better life but
better
i don't know like opportunities
i guess
you can say but i know like i'm gonna
make it out this game for sure
i'm not gonna be 30 plus in this game
it's not me have you been in love before
have you been in love before
i don't think so
if it takes that long to answer the
answer is no
yeah
you're young you're young
i don't think so um
i
i had a baby
i was in love with my baby
of course
are you raising your child
um i actually i was pregnant for about
like six and a half months and then i
had a stillbirth oh i see i'm sorry it's
okay
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you
um
being safe
for sure being safe especially
down at south central
yeah
it's crazy out there
i don't want i've
i've had so many things happen to me i'm
i'm surprised i'm still here yeah
there's girls that have died
yeah there's this girl um
i think you interviewed her essence yeah
essence and butter both passed away who
butter was another one oh wow
yeah both in the last year
it's crazy because i had seen her murder
yeah
that's sad and she's crazy
i've had i've seen girls get um
ran over
this girl
um she
got killed maybe like two weeks ago on a
on a 83rd
um and it was this trick who
ended up like getting out the car and
like beating literally the life out of
her this is somebody other than essence
that essence was shot
yeah
she was shot
yeah it happened so often that
you would think a lot of girls would
just say that not for me
i've been there i'm like you know what
i'm done with this but
it's the lifestyle it's
it's the money
how do you think working the streets has
changed you
i'm more tough
you get streetwise for sure i'm more
street smart
and
i'm more tough i don't take [ __ ]
do you see men differently because of
this yeah
[Laughter]
men are [ __ ] horny like
men are disgusting men are gross men are
so horny
but honestly
they pay
men are just weird
they have weird like requests at times
so weird oh yeah i've heard about some
of those
what requests have you had
um
twister nipples
um
when i was in kansas city i had this
regular
who like i wouldn't even have sex with
him i wouldn't
do anything like sexual that's in my
eyes but with him like he would have
like a toolbox
with like tweezers and uh and like
tasers and the electrical thing that
like hooks onto his nipples
and like
i'll just like basically like torture
him i guess
and then call him like
my little [ __ ] and [ __ ] like that and
like he'll nut
but he would pay me like 600
yeah
that i've had this other guy
who
um basically wanted me to like [ __ ]
with a dildo
but that was in vegas
so
i broke on him
for sure broke on him i'm not gonna [ __ ]
you with a dildo for 200 500
no
he was white too
it's always the white ones yeah
the white guys are weird my cards are
kind of weird i think i think they're
all weird at all everyone's weird
[Laughter]
do you have any regrets in your life yet
yet
um
yeah
a couple
they're really um
it's like sad
like
my grandma had um
passed away
in
december and
everyone was calling me but i was
ignoring everyone i didn't know she
passed away until like two weeks later
and um
i was actually trapping
out of town
and i was like ignoring everyone
yeah that's harsh
sorry that's right
yeah it's hard she was um
she was like my best friend
we were both named the same
both born in the same month
literally like i was her twin
so yeah it was it's it's been hard
and then i went like on a binge
of like hennessy and i was just drunk
all the time that that was probably like
the only time where i would work and
i'll be drunk
because i was just hurt yeah but alcohol
is generally not a problem for you
mm-hmm it's good
it can't be because it raises my blood
sugar
it's great that you're staying away from
drugs because
once the addiction drug addiction
happens it's going to be so much harder
for a girl to get out of that you lose
yourself for sure like i've seen girls
literally like pretty as me
making money and stuff
and they either choose up with
a pimp and he does it so he like
introduces her to it or like she just
had like a rough night and she's like
let me just take the edge off or
you know and you just get lost
you just get lost and you're literally
like just lost in the game yeah because
you could easily
get out of this lifestyle and change
your whole life direction exactly
tomorrow
[Music]
you know it's just a different mindset
but not with drugs not with drugs no no
even like
a heavy like alcoholic drinker
alcohol drinker alcoholic
that yeah no
it's sad
what hours will you typically work
um i work all hours so
yes the day before yesterday i was up 24
hours really yeah how do you do that
without drugs
coffee
coffee and water and red bull that's all
yeah
that's that's that's yeah it's an
interesting street oh yeah i mean it's
like it depends like where you are
though for sure
like i i feel like the 60s
i don't like playing there there's a
bunch of pimps yeah a lot of times
there's a bunch of pimps she's driving
around and
just
i'm good afternoon if it wasn't for the
pimps
i believe figaro because the cops are
not really the problem yeah the pimps
are the problems they've told us plenty
of times like we don't care about you
guys we just
want to get these pimps out and like
we're trying to find guys with guns and
yeah but but i've thought about this a
lot sometimes you'll drive down figaro
street it's like a fashion show oh for
sure absolutely right
it's better than going to a strip club
these girls are beautiful and they come
in all shapes and sizes and colors and
everything
yeah and if it wasn't for the pimp pimps
you'd have five times as many women out
there for sure and right now you already
have like 100 girls
between standing in like one streets
like 20 girls between 64th and and
century you are 105th you've got yeah
literally 100 girls more than that
literally more than 100 girls for sure
from like the 60s up to like the
hundreds but you imagine if there were
no pimps
way more you had 400 girls out there way
more
i know
girls don't come out at a certain time
and they don't play
certain places because they know okay
like pimps be there yeah so no the pimps
have ruined it
yeah some pimps
some pimps some pimps some pimps for
sure
people love to hate pimps
they're the most hated
pedophiles in the
[Music]
in society
but i will say that there are some
i get i get a lot of crap for this but
there are some pimps that are actually
helping their girls
what people don't understand i think is
there a lot of
white people middle class people upper
class don't understand that
in the hood
there aren't a whole lot of options even
though you went to college you still
probably
relate to the situation you're in
and give once you're in that situation
i feel like
no one is in the right place to
judge
criticize
anybody
i could be the most successful person i
like
all this stuff but you will not
understand
what it takes to be a three or four what
it takes to be a pimp what it takes to
like really be out there if you've never
been out here
so it just really
upsets me how people
perceive us as these bad people
as these drug addicts as this has that
but you've never really like
even really sat down and talked to a
person
that's in this lifestyle you've never
been in this lifestyle so who are you to
judge yeah i think what a lot of people
also don't understand is i mean you
might be the exception i think you are
but
you have an education you have good
childhood all that but
a lot of people don't understand
that
a lot of these people the pimps and the
girls are dealing with lack of
opportunity drug addiction traumatic
childhoods
mental illness there's
females out here who've been raped at
six five seven years old
and it's a traumatic
experience like it really really is
you're you're a kid
you're a kid and you've got rape and you
don't think that's gonna take a toll it
does
you're around um drug
addicts
you don't have any
family
people beat on you
i mean me like i've uh
i've been in a domestic violence like
relationship
bad
bad bad bad i was um
i was pregnant at the time
and
i was pregnant at the time and it was
the day before my birthday
and i had just got my hair done i had
just bought like new chains and stuff he
literally
beat the life out of me
he snatched all my chains off i had to
go to the hospital because i had a
fractured rib
while i was pregnant
yeah
i suck yeah it's a terrible lifestyle i
mean one of the girls i just interviewed
recently
calls me and says uh
she just got gang raped by for four gang
members or whatever they were
that's another thing too i see girls out
like
and this is especially like in the 60s i
don't know why
but this is like what a lot of girls do
like there'll be four men in the car or
three men in the car and they all want
to date so she gets in the car i would
never do that that's what happened to
her
afterwards she couldn't even work
because she was so beaten up
yeah i would uh so i helped her with the
room but that's just that's
that's reason to quit right there
there's a lot of reasons to quit and
that's really one of them yeah
it's it's it's just it's just sad it's a
sad lifestyle at times at times they're
it's it's the best
you know like
there's days where you make 400 500
there's days where you make 2 000.
so there's is ups and downs but honestly
what keeps me motivated
is
my mentality the way i am
and my folks
i have a great relationship with him
so
with me being so self-motivated and on
top of that i have him
which is
it it's good it's really good
so before
um i had came here
like here um
i was on a i was in the 80s
and i have my back turned
and i'm on my phone
and i hear a car like coming and stop
so i'm like what the heck so then
as soon as i turn around all i hear is
they hit me with a whole bb gun multiple
times
multiple times
and i started crying my eyes out because
it hurt like i started crying my eyes
out and um
they hit me like about like 20 times and
like
my side right here and then like my back
they hit me once here but i turned
around like fast and i was wearing heels
so i can't run or else like i'll fall
and they're still gonna like shoot me
with the bb gun
but then um i was just i was so over it
and i was gonna go inside and then
thankfully
i got an interview
with you guys from the streets for a bit
yeah
just tiring
tired i've been up since like 8 p.m
yesterday you've been up since 8 p.m
and what time is it now like it's uh
11 00 yeah i've been up since 8 pm and
still i'm going to still be up
you're going to work again
after this
by choice or you kind of have to
nothing's by force
no nothing's by force how many days a
week do you work
seven
so you don't take days off
no i take breaks like
in between my day and stuff but
there's
no days off
by choice though
honestly
there's a lot of pimps out there that
it's by force
but when it's
slow days like this you got a gorilla
hoe
you really have to gorilla hoe and
really like you're going to date me
so is is robbing the trick part of the
i i suspect it is a lot of girls every
prostitute and if you don't
every prostitute has robbed a trick
before
every prostitute tell me your best story
okay um
it was this out of towner
um he was where was he from
new york
brooklyn
and
um he had ended up
first paying me like
150.
but
what tricks don't understand is if you
pull out a stack of money and you think
i'm not going to ask you for more or you
think i'm not going to rob me because
i'm a sweet girl and all this like you
have something coming because
i'm here for the money
literally i'm not here to to
to fall in love i'm no i'm here because
you're paying me you're paying for a
time i'm a great time i'm really loving
i'm really caring i'm really really
sweet i'm not like most
females who
want to rush you and who are
you know really like mean and really
rude because at the end of the day
you're paying me
so we're gonna have a good time for the
time that you pay there's this trick he
ended up paying me 150 dollars but he
pulled out a stack of money i'm like
you're not going to just pay me 150 i'm
going to break on you
so he ended up paying me another 150
and
while i was doing what i was doing
he had ended up putting
the stack in his pockets but on the
floor so i did what i did
and he was closing his eyes i'm like
yeah baby just close your eyes relax
calm down i i'ma take care of you
doing what i'm doing i reach down
and
i'm trying to find like where it's at i
could feel it with my foot i could feel
it with my foot so i grab my foot
and i like pull it way closer to me so i
grab my hand i ended up just grabbing
the stack
and
i'm not going to say where i hid it but
i hit it good
i heard good
and then he ended up walking me to the
door
he's like okay babe like it was great
seeing you i'm like yes babe what did
you get away with
it was like six bands
wow
and he didn't even nut
i promise you you didn't even know
it was just like because
that's the what the game really is yeah
you guys won't say that when they say
they get beaten up by a trick
what they're not telling you is that
they're doing something like that and
then the guy rolls down fig and finds
them three weeks exactly and i'm not
going to give out too much free game out
there but don't do it and you know he
lives out here
be smart
be smart
like
no
but that's what the game is really about
you have to have a mouthpiece for sure
you need you need to have a mouthpiece
you need to be laced properly you need
to have game and not be scared because
scare money doesn't make no money
so
chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
okay um just to be safe in your 23 years
just to be safe especially doing this as
a female
you know just be safe be
mindful and be
aware of like your surroundings for sure
um
don't trust people
literally do not trust people and if you
have someone that you can trust like
hold on to them because that's rare
um
as a prostitute as a 304
all your hps and your homegirls and all
this stuff like
take it to a certain extent
because you literally never know people
can literally turn around and stab you
in the back for the littlest things ever
and just you know have fun too
don't be so
addicted to this that you lose yourself
so i've been there
yeah just be safe that's it
all right chris thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you be careful
out there
you